corona hotspot sachsen die impfzentren
öffnen in deutschlands am schwersten
betroffene region doch der impfstoff
bleibt auch dort knapp ringen um die
strategie in den usa warten viele bürger
mit spannung wie demokraten und
republikaner mit den letzten tagen der
ära zu umgehen themen für super walia
die grünen gehen online in klausur und
stecken ab wofür sie in bund und ländern
politisch werben wollen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend ich begrüße
sie herzlich zu einer neuen nachrichten
woche zusammen mit norbert lehmann den
sport dabei hat einen namen durch von
mir die korona lage in deutschland hat
heute zwei schwerpunkte zum einen gelten
jetzt striktere regeln
zum anderen gibt es neues beim thema
impfen bayon kündigte an dieses jahr
deutlich mehr impfstoff zu produzieren
und der impfstoff von us hersteller
moderner soll schon morgen an die länder
ausgeliefert werden
damit steigt die hoffnung dass die
impfkampagne nun schneller vorankommt
denn noch immer sind mehr als fünf
millionen über 80 jährige die zu hause
wohnen nicht geimpft insgesamt meldet
das rk ii bislang klappt über 613.000
erste impfungen das sind 0,74 prozent
der gesamtbevölkerung schlusslicht ist
mitunter 0,5 prozent sachsen das
besonders von der pandemie betroffen ist
dort wurden jetzt die impfzentren
geöffnet cornelia schiemenz es ist nur
ein kleiner anfang für mehr fehlt
einfach der impfstoff in sachsen starten
am morgen 13 impfzentren für alle
zusammenstehen pro tag maximal 2.000
impfdosen bereit
auch deshalb fordert die
sozialministerin dringend mehr impfstoff
für das corona gebeutelte sachsen
es geht einfach um den vorteil
mechanismus von impfstoff dass wir
tatsächlich gesagt haben dass die
einwohnerzahlen alleine kein kriterium
sein sollten sondern dass man mehr
kriterien alle kriterien ansetzen sollte
kriterien wie hohe inzidenz zahlen hohe
altersdurchschnitt grenznähe
bislang reicht der impfstoff hier
erstmal nur für das medizinische
personal im ambulanten bereich
wir haben wirklich alle energie
reingesteckt dass wir ab heute
kontinuierlich in allen impfzentren an
den start gehen und das passiert jetzt
in den augenblicken allem wann beginnen
wir haben das auch so aus geplant dass
in jedem im zentrum jeden tag geimpft
ab nächster woche sollen in den
impfzentren die über 80-jährigen geimpft
werden vorausgesetzt sie bekommen einen
termin
mein mann ist 98 88 unternehmen wir
anders wenn der aufforderung bekommen
hoffen wir
ich bin lieber 80 nur weiß wann ich dran
bin
den termin weiß ich nicht ich denke dass
ich zu der gruppe gehören
in der zweiten kategorie und dann den
impftermin zugeschickt bekomme per brief
wird in sachsen niemand informiert über
das internet oder telefonisch muss der
termin vereinbart werden das online
portal ist heute am ersten tag zusammen
gebrochen wegen technischer probleme
aktueller im weltmeister ist israel also
das land das besonders hohe
infektionsraten hatte und noch immer mit
corona kämpft stand heute haben dort
bereits rund 1,9 millionen menschen denn
bei antec pfizer impfstoff bekommen etwa
21 prozent der bevölkerung auch drive in
stationen gehören zur impfkampagne
schnell soll es vor allem gehen
datenschutz und ausführliche
aufklärungsgespräche bleiben mitunter
auf der strecke michael de warum israel
macht weiter tempo beim impfen nach
einem kurzen aufklärungsgespräch
wirklich spritze aufgezogen impfung nach
burbach
fertig seit gestern wird den ersten
bereits die zweite dosis verabreicht die
israelis sehen nun licht am ende des
tunnels die zweite impfung bald können
wir uns wieder umarmen
die zweite dosis endlich ich bin sehr
aufgeregt und hoffe dass es der anfang
vom ende
im ganzen land wird dezentral und sieben
tage die woche geimpft in nur drei
wochen haben fast 1,9 millionen menschen
mindestens eine impfdosis erhalten das
sind über 20 prozent der bevölkerung
israel damit in weltmeister die gründe
dafür
es gibt nur vier krankenkassen doch die
haben mehr kompetenzen
sie verfügen über eigene
gesundheitszentren und mobile teams auch
die alten und pflegeheime wurden
durchgeimpft impfkampagne wird zentral
gesteuert und von staat und armee
unterstützt zusätzlich laufen auf allen
kanälen spots die aufklären und für die
impfung seien unsere kassen sind sehr
geübt in diesen dingen wenn so eine
infektion auf sie zukommt können sie
schnell personal einstellen dass
ausbilden und die logistik leiten um die
bürger zu erreichen
die wiederum verlassen sich auf sie und
machen außerdem hat sich die regierung
frühzeitig zu höheren preisen bei und
eckpfeiler im stop gesichert erst
gestern wurden 700.000 dosen
nachgeliefert ministerpräsident
netanjahu nahm sie wie steht
werbewirksam selbst in empfang in israel
sind alt war und auch pfizer profitiert
vom israelischen im erfolg wohl nicht
nur imagemässig nach berichten erhält
das unternehmen besonderen zugriff auf
die daten des imf weltmeisters corona
impfungen in deutschland nicht alle
wollen mitmachen stellen sie ihre fragen
an die sozialpsychologin cornelia betsch
um halb acht bei zdf heute live über
youtube facebook oder unsere app wie
schon eingangs erwähnt gelten ab heute
ja strengere bestimmungen in sachen
corona das hatten bund und länder letzte
woche beschlossen weil die
infektionszahlen einfach nicht runter
gehen wo welche einschränkungen wirksam
sind und wo es ausnahmen gibt erklärt
uns thomas kunz
wochenbeginn mit winterspaziergang und
mit neuen beschränkungen wie hier in
mainz darf sich ein haushalt nur mit
einer person treffen
die kann zwar täglich jemand anderes
sein denn noch das alltagsleben hat noch
engere grenzen werben um verständnis
es macht wenig sinn geschäfte schulen
das öffentliche leben runter zu fahren
und zu schließen wenn gleichzeitig im
privaten zahlreiche kontakte zahlreiche
treffen stattfinden viel weniger
begegnungen draußen ist das überall
verpflichtend für privatwohnungen
spricht rheinland pfalz nur von einem
sollen in hessen und nordrhein westfalen
gilt nur eine empfehlung warum
sonderwege erst letzte woche ganz klare
beschlüsse der ministerpräsidenten und
der kanzlerin private zusammenkünfte
sollen eingeschränkt werden auch in der
wohnung und jetzt scheren doch wieder
einige bundesländer aus und verweisen
dabei auf die unverletzlichkeit der
wohnung und die schwierigkeit von
kontroll ausnahmen von der regel
beispielsweise auch bei kindern in
brandenburg bremen und baden württemberg
gibt es für sie bei treffen keine
obergrenze in bayern keine für
kleinkinder länder flickenteppich auch
beim bewegungsradius für hot spots mit
einer instanz über 200 g nordrhein
westfalen und niedersachsen entscheiden
darüber die kommunen baden württemberg
macht gar nicht mit welche neuerungen
gelten wo jeder sollte sich konkret
informieren denn bußgelder drohen wie
hoch auch das ist wen wundert's regional
unterschiedlich neue regeln viele
ausnahmen was aktuell geld haben wir in
unserer app für sie zusammengefasst
dort bieten wir auch einen überblick
über die abweichungen in den einzelnen
ländern
neun tage noch läuft die amtszeit von
donald trotzdem wollen die us-demokraten
dass der präsident nach dem sturm seiner
anhänger auf das kapitol offiziell
abgesetzt wird
zwei möglichkeiten gibt es vizepräsident
pence müsste zusammen mit dem kabinett
trump für amtsunfähig erklären und ein
parlamentarisches
amtsenthebungsverfahren beides stießen
die demokraten heute an sie wollen
möglichst verhindern dass trump 2004
20 noch einmal kandidiert britta jäger
berichtet eine resolution für eine
amtsenthebung von us-präsident trump
eingebracht von den demokraten im
repräsentantenhaus der vorwurf
anstiftung zum aufruhr
zeitgleich hatten die demokraten
vizepräsident mike pence aufgerufen den
fünfundzwanzigster verfassungszusatz
anzuwenden um trump vorzeitig aus dem
amt zu entfernen
die resolution fordert vizepräsident
mike pence auf die mitglieder des
kabinetts einzuberufen und dem
präsidenten mit dem 25 verfassungszusatz
für unfähig zu erklären seine
amtsgeschäfte auszuführen
unwahrscheinlich dass der vizepräsident
der aufforderung folgen wird und so
könnte das demokratisch geführte
repräsentantenhaus nun wohl am mittwoch
über die amtsenthebung trumps abstimmen
wir tolerieren das nicht und wir werden
nicht tolerieren dass diese person
jemals wieder ihren schatten über die
stufen der amerikanischen regierung wird
die demokraten wollen mit der
amtsenthebung vor allem sein politisches
comeback verhindern das verfahren im
senat wollen sie aber erst 100 tage nach
beiden amtseinführung eröffnen um dem
nachfolger den staat nicht zu erschweren
die geschehnisse am kapitol vergleicht
arnold schwarzenegger unterdessen mit
der reichspogromnacht mittwoch war die
nacht des zerbrochenen glas es hier in
den vereinigten staaten
sie sind auf den prinzipien
herumgetrampelt auf denen die usa
gegründet worden sind donald trumps
letzte tage im weißen haus sie werden
noch turbulenter als befürchtet der
frage an ines trams in washington ist
eine so späte amtsenthebung trumps
überhaupt in beiden sind ja die
demokraten sind hin und hergerissen bei
den demokraten im abgeordnetenhaus gibt
es tatsächlich ein sehr starkes momentum
für ein amtsenthebungsverfahren ein
sogenanntes impeachment sie sehen in
präsident trump den geistigen anstifter
des tumults von mittwoch des des sturms
auf das kapitol sie wollen ihn abstrafen
sie wollen ihn zur rechenschaft ziehen
mit einem weiteren am
enthebung verfahren und es lockt sie
außerdem die möglichkeit mit einem
solchen engagement auch zu verhindern
das jump jemals wieder ein öffentliches
bundesamt besetzen darf aber es gibt
auch bei den demokraten skeptiker und zu
diesen skeptikern gehört tatsächlich
auch der designierte präsident joe biden
sie die skeptiker befürchten dass ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren den neuen
kongress zu viel zeit und energie rauben
könnte joe biden will schnellstmöglich
mit seiner politik beginnen er will sie
umsetzen er will seine minister
kandidaten im senat durchbringen all das
würde verzögert werden und es gibt dann
auch noch einen eher übergeordneten
gedanken ein amtsenthebungsverfahren
würde von den tramp anhängern sicherlich
als rache der demokraten verstanden und
entsprechend würde ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren land und politik
sicherlich weiter zerreißen nicht
zusammenbringen
vielen dank für ihre erklärung danke ist
ramms trumps wichtigstes sprachrohr
bleibt stumm
twitter hat den us-präsidenten dauerhaft
gesperrt
die bundesregierung sieht das kritisch
soziale netzwerke seien zwar
verantwortlich dafür wenn kommunikation
durch hass und anstiftung zur gewalt
vergiftet werde sagte regierungssprecher
seibert
aber eingriffe in das grundrecht auf
meinungsfreiheit könnten nur durch den
gesetzgeber geregelt werden nicht von
unternehmen
deswegen finde es die kanzlerin
problematisch dass die konten trumps
gesperrt worden sein
auch die grünen sind zum auftakt des
superwahljahres in klausur gegangen dass
sie auch im bund regieren wollen ist
kein geheimnis wer kanzlerkandidat oder
kandidatin wird das wollen sie bis ende
mai entscheiden zu marschroute und
schwerpunkten der grünen aus berlin
genetische unternehmen zwei
nebeneinander platz die sich viel
vorgenommen haben für dieses jahr
corona aber überlagert alles deshalb
fordern die grünen kurzfristig weitere
maßnahmen jetzt nicht erst ende januar
wenn sich bund und länder
treffen ssp zwei masken für alle
änderungen am arbeitsplatz das bedeutet
vor allen dingen in der arbeitswelt
überall wo es dort möglich ist wirklich
home office jetzt auch anzuordnen als
konsequenz aus der krise wollen die
grünen dass der staat mehr investiert
500 milliarden euro für innenstädte
schulen schwimmbäder bibliotheken das
sind die orte wo menschen
unterschiedlichen unterschiedlich
unterschiedlicher herkunft
unterschiedlichen bildungsgrad des
einkommens geschlechts miteinander
gemeinsam den raum teilen gemeinsame
erlebnisse haben gemeinsam
diskussionsraum auch haben
deswegen ist der dritte punkt ein
massives investieren in diese
öffentlichen räume die
teilhabegerechtigkeit und zugänge zur
gesellschaft dann sicherstellen
berbalk und harbeck sind seit gut zwei
jahren parteivorsitzende legen wert auf
gutes miteinander nicht gegeneinander
david fitz kanzleramt kandidieren das
werden wir zwischen ostern und pfingsten
wenn die bäume wieder grün sind so schön
wie das michael kellner gesagt hat dann
gemeinsam alt parteivorsitzende
entscheiden in die bundestagswahl zieht
die partei als underdog so sagt sie es
selbst das letzte jahr habe aber oft
gezeigt dass das unmögliche möglich sei
und jetzt einblick in die wirtschaft ein
traditionsunternehmen der deutschen
modebranche sucht die rettung im
insolvenzverfahren
die adler modemärkte mit ihren gut 3300
mitarbeiter innen
die überschuldung sei zu hoch teilte das
unternehmen mit
grund ist der shutdown das geschäft soll
aber erst einmal weiterlaufen adler will
sich in eigenregie sanieren
isabel de la vega über händler in not
für die branche ist es ein alarmsignal
zwar schwächelte die modekette adler mit
ihren über 170 filialen schon vor corona
doch der shutter und verschlimmerte die
lage
das unternehmen ist insolvent adler
könnte ein vorbote sein für die folgen
der korona maßnahmen im einzelhandel
wir befürchten dass 50.000 unternehmen
nicht alleine diese krise durchstehen
können weil das eigenkapital
aufgebraucht wurde und wir leider auch
befürchten dass eine insolvenzwelle im
einzelhandel dafür sorgen wird dass in
vielen innenstädten das licht ausgeht
während der umsatzeinbruch im
stationären handel dramatisch ist
profitiert der online- und versandhandel
vom shutdown mit einem plus im letzten
jahr von über 23 prozent corona
beschleunigt den strukturwandel im
handel
wer überhaupt jetzt erstmal lernen muss
wie kommt es funktioniert ja tatsächlich
etwas verschlafen und braucht es in
weckhoven das kleine kaufhaus meter in
frankfurt braucht keinen weckruf online
bestelltes kann hier abgeholt werden der
spielzeug und haushalts laden hat einen
online-shop und berät die kunden seit
corona per videochat haben wir auch im
dezember den online-umsatz und fast
verdreifacht im geld verhältnis zum
dezember letzten jahres
allerdings ist es immer noch auf
niedrigem niveau
ein anteil von fünf prozent oder sogar
vom gesamtumsatz digitaler zu werden
kann den stationären handel allein nicht
retten denn der lebt vom shopping
erlebnis und der beratung wegen des
verlängerten shutdowns fordert die
branche mehr staatshilfe um weitere
insolvenzen zu verhindern
zum weltklimagipfel in paris hat eu
kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
vor dem risiko neuer pandemien gewarnt
vor allem weil die weltweite
artenvielfalt weiter zurückgehen
ein zweites thema frankreichs präsident
ma con machte sich stark für das projekt
einer großen grünen mauer in der sahel
zone
dabei sollen über eine strecke von 8000
kilometern bäume gepflanzt werden von
dakar bis dschibuti ziel ist es die
ausbreitung der sahara zu stoppen
süd europa erlebt gerade beim wetter
einen januar der extreme in spanien
kommen nach dem rekord schnee rund um
madrid jetzt einige nächte polare
kaltluft mit minus
zehn grad und noch darunter eine
herausforderung für die menschen hier
die zum teil keine heizung haben und
gleichzeitig gut 2000 kilometer weiter
östlich griechenland und der südwind aus
afrika um die 25 grad
da zieht's die athena sogar an die
strände und ins wasser
und nun zu dir norbert und zur
erfolgreichsten deutschen nation
handball nationalspieler hat sich
gestern abend vorzeitig für die em 2022
qualifiziert durch einen souveränen 34
zu 20 sieg gegen österreich eine
gelungene generalprobe für die halb für
die handball-weltmeisterschaft die
übermorgen beginnt jetzt doch ohne
zuschauer gestern abend kam die
bestätigung leere ränge nun also auch
bei der wm in ägypten nachdem zunächst
mit bis zu 30 prozent
zuschauerauslastung geplant worden war
was auch immer vernünftiger ohne
zuschauer zu spielen dass man dadurch
wieder ein stück weit sicherer ist und
die vorfreude steigt von tag zu tag
sportlich gesehen fliegen die deutschen
mit rückenwind gen süden nach dem
deutlichen sieg gegen österreich vor
allem die neu formierte abwehr
funktioniert besser als zuletzt
die stimmung ist gut und wird auch
glaube ich von tag zu tag besser nicht
gerade zwei spiele gegen österreich uns
glaube ich auch mal ein bisschen
auftrieb gegeben morgen früh 10 uhr hebt
der flieger ab ziel kairo und minimum
wm-viertelfinale mit zuschauern dagegen
wird das erste grand slam tennisturnier
des jahres stattfinden die australian
open in melbourne statt achter februar
mit einem strengen hygiene konzept
melbourne schön aber unerreichbar denn
australien ist abgeriegelt für ausländer
nur tennis stars dürfen jetzt rein
ausnahmsweise für die australian open
das ist der beste platz für so ein
turnier die ganze welt stöhnt wegen
corona aber wir haben praktisch keine
fälle mehr
man sollte das nicht erlauben es kann
immer ein spieler dazwischen sein der
krone hat deshalb sind 14 tage hotel
quarantäne pflicht tägliche freigang
maximal fünf stunden zum training die
teams bleiben unter sich keine begegnung
bis zum spiel die isolation dient dem
schutz der spieler und ihrer betreuer
und sie soll uns alle schützen
falls im spielerkreis eine infektion
auftritt darf sie nicht um sich greift
sogar zuschauer sollen dabei sein doch
der plan steht unter vorbehalt dass das
virus mitspielt oder besser dass es eben
nicht mitspielt beim ersten tennis
höhepunkt des jahres auch die golf welt
wendet sich von us-präsident ramp up das
major-turnier pga championships wird
2022 nicht auf trams golfkurs im batman
-star new jersey stattfinden
hintergrund der entscheidung des us golf
verbandes die ausschreitungen von trump
anhängern im capitol das was du ja danke
neuschnee und glätte sind für die
kommende nacht und morgen angesagt mehr
dazu gleich beim wetter von essent elli
so viel von uns mehr gibt es um drei
viertel 10 mit dem heute journal mit
bettina schausten
wir danken für interesse wünschen einen
angenehmen abend und sagen tschüss bis
morgen
[Musik]
ein schön genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter neuer regen und
neuer schnee erreichte uns von norden
her zunächst einmal kommt regen und
dieser regen geht allmählich in der
mitte dann in schnee über und breitete
sich dann morgen im tagesverlauf bis an
die alpen aus und dann morgen im
nordwesten lockert es schon wieder auf
das erst einmal zur übersicht schauen
wir uns die details an
in der nacht von südwest bis nach
nordost in diesem schraffierten bereich
große glättegefahr durch schnee oder
glatteis ansonsten im nordwesten und
nach norden viele wolken mit regen im
süden erst einmal trocken da kommt regen
und schnee später an
es geht hauptsächlich dann in schnee
über und das bei temperaturen von minus
zwölf grad an den alpen und 5 grad im
nordwesten morgen also weiterer regen
und schnee im süden auch nach norden
aber je lässt allmählich nach und das
bei temperaturen von null grad im
vogtland und 8 grad ganz im westen
deutschlands
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage am
mittwoch folgt weiterer regen und auch
schnee bei minus 1 bis 6 grad und ab
donnerstag wird es kälter und der schnee
hauptsächlich dann in den südlichen
landesteilen ein schöner abend